[Musique]
dans une grande et vieille ville comme
paris il y as pour qu'il ya le temps et
le goût de les chercher bien les décors
inattendue
c'est soudain le spectacle d'un vieux
métiers qui s'exerce encore derrière la
vitre d'une boutique écartée
c'est une galerie de l'ancienne noblesse
disparaît peu à peu et où dorment dans
les classeurs d'une petite librairie
quelques images du vieux paris
depuis longtemps la ville a été comparé
un grand navire
elle en a les masses innombrables
et rangée de et blu serré ouvert sur le
large
les hulot au perche et où s'abritent les
cloches et au long des siècles ont sonné
au dessus de cette mère perpétuellement
changeantes toutes les heures de la
ville
[Musique]
l'idée du navire se retrouve sur les
vieux saut comme au fronton les grands
hôtels et sur la scène autrefois large
et 1 certaines rivières ce grand navire
s'est ancré depuis plus de 2000 ans de
ce temps là il ne reste presque rien de
lutèce si ce n'est la forme de l'île
alors plus petit et plus à fleur d'eau
et sur la petite montagne que nous
nommons salle geneviève et que les
romains avaient choisi pour s'établir
quelques vieilles pierres retrouvées
dans la cité nous attendent là les
visages presque effacé des notes c'est
bateliers gaulois travaillant sous la
protection de roms sont les plus vieux
parisien que nous puissions rencontrer
sur ce pilier ils ont remercié leur dieu
pour son divin à présent le fleuve le
fleuve il faut toujours revenir à lui
quand on parle des premiers siècles de
paris il a remporté les parcs d'invasion
refléter les incendies reçu les morts et
surtout il a protégé la ville jusqu'à ce
qu'elle soit grande et forte
de l'enchevêtrement des rues et des
maisons du moyen-âge il ne reste que
bien peu de choses
dans l'île de la cité aux murs du palais
du roi une horloge la première qui bat
au coeur de paris depuis 1334 de tours
de bonnets pointus tour bonbecs ainsi
nommée parce qu'on ligue avait un
supplice les suspectes et tour d'argent
la sainte chapelle du roi louis et à
l'autre extrémité de ville la cathédrale
de l'évêque maurice de celui notre dame
de paris
austère indestructible demeure dans la
cour d'une école latour ou gens que l'on
disait sans peur se cachait
[Musique]
demeure aussi dans la rue des archives
la porte de l'ancien hôtel de clisson
et dans une petite rue très étroite
une maison une seule de ce temps là qui
a résisté aux effets du progrès
[Musique]
près de la seine rue des jardins saint
paul actuelle royaume des chiffonniers
il y a aussi un vieux mur noir qui
n'attire même pas l'attention des
parisiens et de rabelais qui va mourir
là disait voyez ici ces belles muraille
par ma barbe une vache avec un bep en
abattre est plus de 6 brasse cependant
bien les parisiens gardent encore un
reste le long de leur maison ou dans
leurs cours de cette enceinte que
philippe auguste fit construire autour
de la ville pendant des siècles et des
siècles des générations de parisiens
furent ensevelis dans le terrain vague
du cimetière des innocents
le réseau idc chez ensuite dans les
charniers et l'été la ville s'emplissait
l'odeur insupportable dans ses miasmes
des femmes prier jusqu'à leur mort murer
dans les reclus zwar une religieuse
soeur alix labour got y fut 48 ans seul
au centre des halles
dans le bruit des moteurs et les cris
des marchands notre fontaine des
innocents rappelle l'ancien cimetière et
là même où les crânes au rebut
s'entassaient s'entassent
orange et tout victoire
le souvenir du 15e siècle revit dans
l'hôtel de sens
[Musique]
et dans le petit château de la reine
blanche qui demeure dans la cour d'une
usine près des gobelins il y à aussi à
belleville tout modeste le petit regard
de la l'antenne d'où partaient les eaux
des sources qui sous terre sont allés
rafraîchir à paris
les moines de saint martin des champs au
16ème siècle la ville est déjà grande
et du haut de la colline de montmartre
où les peintres sont déjà installés
nous voyons maison et monastères qui
déborde l'enceinte de charles 5
[Musique]
il faut bientôt la compléter d'un
nouveau rempart qui savent a rejoint
alors la scène
à la porte de la conférence un nouveau
décor se prépare c'est celui de la
renaissance amoureusement conservé par
israël sylvestre grave de paris les
maisons plus gai entoure maintenant les
donjons aux aveugles du châtelet et la
vieille tour de nesle et se ruinent
lentement
le louvre féodal s'effondre pour faire
place au palais que nous connaissons
dont l'architecte pierre lescot
construisit la première elle
henri iv fait ouvrir à la pointe de la
cité la place dauphine dont les deux
charmant pavillon qui donne sur le
pont-neuf aurait pu se passer sur les
vieilles gravures d'une entrée si large
flatteuse mais faut aussi
les commerçants yacou et s'installe et
d'une fenêtre d'une boutique de cartes à
jouer
nous pouvons voir toute l'animation de
paris
le pont-neuf fera pendant plusieurs
siècles un succès triomphant ce sera le
pont l'on danse longchamp où l'on vend
l'ont souvent un peu aussi henri iv
avait fait construire en même temps une
énorme pompe qu'on appela la samaritaine
et dont les roues de moulins distribuer
l'eau à la ville comme au puits de jacob
la femme d'un halo à jésus tandis qu'au
milieu du fleuve tournait en chantant
d'autres ou celle des meuniers flottants
car la scène alors source de toute
richesse droit y est aussi la farine du
pain quotidien
[Musique]